so reist noch 321 mal wieder die sie in
ihr heim und armenien
schön
susan woods amerika ihre wurzeln finden
und ihre farbe besser kennenlernen
[Musik]
und seidenberg sind hier nur letzte
versuch ihre lieblichkeit kinder
hab nichts
die sitze
zurück zu den wurzeln 30 mini fremdheit
[Musik]
als dreijährige vor schweizer adoptiert
worden
jetzt wo sie endlich ihre lieblings
mutter finde sie hat alles probiert sie
schuften gemeint sie die
adoptionsagentur und weise wie sony
erfolg sei dass es nicht nur ihre
wurzeln sie mozart kultur für ihre
freunde heimat keine lehre und das stück
zuvor mit einer
[Musik]
ich finde ich mich beim mini aus insulin
metro in die bezirke als zu europa ja
ich bin moment ist noch nicht bevor mit
einer viele schöne farbe von facebook an
der zeit ist
es braucht
[Musik]
lässt
die letzten tage rückschläge erlebt jede
spur im sand verlaufen und trotzdem
buddy rice klasse und der indische autor
dort zur karibik schoss
[Musik]
ich finde doch jetzt mehr ordentlich
kann so vielen mit der nähe zum medium
also wenn ja wie viele kontakte männer
21 viel mehr dulden unternehmen auf
euro-staaten bei dem bekommen denn in
der kunst
[Applaus]
wenn alles menschenmögliche mitbringt
denn hoffentlich sony version haftstrafe
mit dem guru ist es leider ihre letzte
hoffnung
am flug aufwärts ihre waren wir über
sehnsüchtig erwartet der ondol endet
nach 3 20 yards erstmal wieder zu
armenien sich freuen die in georgia
begleitet ihn auf der third heimat
amandus jungen und sich die beiden dann
durch sieben xi wo seine familie vor zu
wenig flüchtet ist noch as bari 20
senioren trend und der familie
städtischen vor vier york gestorben
der andere berufe verwandelt man rote
zahlen
[Musik]
jetzt ist gesperrt wie lang schienen sie
die straße machen also probiert jetzt
mal dass jährigen die jungen fahrer ran
musste sich doch sicher mit marina
berlin machte stiftung mit marketing mit
wotan obwohl sie tabu
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
da sich zu fuß von encore sehen erste
berührte von mando sein vater
[Musik]
ich bin
ausstoße mit viel glück wünscht dass
viele erfolge bleibe ich will davor
gesundheit und alles positive und dann
jetzt zunächst seine freundin
ich denke hier kein auto und schlug aber
das ist mir dass ich bin arminia muss
das unbedingt gut 166 jeder selber
gemacht und dann muss ich das probiere
der android profiboxer und sehr streng
mit sich selber aber so eine begrüßung
schnaps die dusche
der onkel sein nimmt der anruf wie sie
eigentum
seit 40 jahren energie für
familienmitglieder promis oder schwyz
nährmedium das hat ihm prophezeit dass
sie zu große familie erfolgreich
verlaufen
[Musik]
unser weg führt am tag vor der 30
pedelecs
[Musik]
angeli
geboren in 64 fax bei unternehmen ist
angie
[Musik]
ein passendes thema ist tollen fans
us dollar in nur haus liegt wenn sie
dich
die rocker sind ist toll in ihr haus ok
[Musik]
ok wack sie den text in textilien
drehachse den wurden jugendhaus ist
total okay
[Musik]
august sein als meine freundin hat
hallo hallo mami einmal nach
[Musik]
in utah
spaß ist im markt nicht möglich vorne
dabei
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir kommen
quatsch erzählen
viel viel neues erfahren
unis geschmeckt haben es wird zum das
alles zu erreichen
letztlich sehr aufgewühlt
gut gemacht
die neuigkeit big thing
beste moment für mich
ja ganz fest
und ich habe für die statistik
und du bist wunderbar geklärt
mit gott und jesus kämpfen und erlebte
mit oder ohne gordon medium gehörst welt
machen
berg wo zeitraum und rookies führt sie
zur antwort auf die frage gefunden aber
nicht hier wo sie sich erhofft hat und
wer weiß vielleicht findet er sich
steht uns irgendwo durch verwandte
[Musik]
jerewan am nächsten morgen der hondo und
georgia sind früher auf der bahn in der
hauptstadt für niveau nicht gut 1
million lüth
forscht das vierteljahrhundert ist
rannten ihm im land vorsieht trixi und
stunde tour ist
muss man festhalten
wahnsinn
nach 3 20 jahre also quasi ist so alt
wie sie ich bin ich gleich mal taxi und
[Musik]
aufregend ja es ist ein
unbeschreibliches gefühl wieder zurück
sie und sehr schön selber unglaublich
[Musik]
als nationalgericht granatapfel
das ist erstmal dass die 22 mal so weit
verreisen
vergiss verankern
außer funktion ist so lieben die fahrer
wie sie war
der regler regler
der heimische pc oder bezug zu sehen
eine armenische wurzeln verloren
ritter kontakt zu seiner mutter und zwei
brüdern abbruch will sie nicht
verstanden dass ihm sie traum vom profi
boxer wichtiger als alles andere
brando entdeckt
[Musik]
dort war willkommen in meiner heimat
amelith im kaukasus gebirge und grenzt
an georgien aserbaidschan türkei und
iran betreten von ivona die tiere waren
die junge und moderne hauptstadt vom
zentrum sind nur das paar minuten fuß
und schon stand mit im grünen
[Musik]
stani vater und die partie dahin
letztlich das schwimmbad gibt ja mache
glück meistens schön hier schwimmen mit
meistens ins lose den bio ist marco h
deshalb seien mit autor
das ist eine ganz große spannung
garantiert wachstum damals greifen
gar nicht wahrzunehmen was du sie weiß
immer wo gab toyota soli
das finde ich nur cool ist ein oldschool
team hat mir das vorstelle
[Musik]
der schweizer meister im super league
wird für ihn geht's freitag ohne
training
direkt an der straße
das getränk jede wand jeder abriss
abriss ist es gut sehr gut hin zum
unbeschwerten built for one die stadt
der braune und risiko und tier wird der
anders in ihre freundin jetzt zeigen
zurück in schwyz glarus die einte fühlt
sich zwischen der mächtige berge von
glarnerland geborgen
der andere wird zum teil meines zu
deinem körper susan stauffacher sie der
usa wollte und nicht nur sehnsucht nach
ihrem geburtsland sondern auch ihrem
vater und ihrer halbschwester
rolle spielt für den und streckt das ist
einfach so mein stock cafés die
vorstellung vom was wird ein hobby rx ep
sie minimierten zu geschwind und der
spielerischen her ist und das ist dran
ruhig und einfach wie strand oder bilder
von kubica extrem vermisst in mekka und
fragte mich mein comeback einfach
kennenlernen und ich habe vor allem
ambrosini der chöre und ich mich nicht
wundern dass alles zugegangen ist
aber jetzt kann alles erwarten die
schwester erwachsenen frauen sind jung
ja ja
versuchen ihre verwunderte ursprünglich
zum zweiten mal kürte ihre halbschwester
grenzhausen huhn mit der jüngere der mlc
forme video für skype
[Musik]
persönlich prof wenn sie sich nun ihr
auf facebook gefunden und kontakte
[Musik]
ich freue mich einfach cousine wie sie
ticken und was man mit den antworten ist
für gemeinsamkeit hat
[Musik]
das ist einfach die freude eierkuchen
mit ihrem vater seit über 20 jahren im
xi eigentliche die remote sie auf die
reise die heimat welle begleitet dann
aber einen rückzieher gemacht
[Musik]
zu nationally begleitet gefunden
ihre freundin monika womit die beide sie
noch bringen und verbringen mit viel
zusammen dessen hier die vergangenheit
die später eine sprach immer wieder das
thema das man ab und zu gemeinsamen buch
kapellenhof sony corp nyse und ich trage
ich was haltet ihr von mir oder wie
steht zu mir sie gern hat für mich ich
glaube das ist so
dieses damoklesschwert gegentore was man
sich mit dem vater und innere haltung zu
mir oder zu dir
[Musik]
tausende schiffe findet ihre worte nur
ganz artig sie die schönste riccione 12x
ich damals ich sie ihn zusammen mit
ihrer mutter zwei wochen als mensch mit
bewusst sich also du denn wirklich zu
einer mit 4 2
denn die usa ausgewandert aber nicht zum
vater durch größten sondern auf
kalifornien hätte sich als künstler
schlagen
das stimmvolk muschel bis acht
heimischen bruttoschulden der die
vorsicht und angst kultur ist vorspiel
jahr lang kalifornien blieben
[Musik]
wann geht's los die die fremdheit of
california und den autor sprüche zu
ihrem vater
[Musik]
eine adoption gestrandeter
sehenswürdigkeiten zeigt lehre zusammen
das sich von der stadt kennen
der grund ohne die ärmste 26 jahre dokus
gesehen und so kommt mir das jetzt in
jerewan vor
auch dell hat alle zusammen sandra
nicole 19 jahren kann man ganz so wie
man namen wohnst gäste waren im einsatz
erlebt man hat gar kündigte die hexe
backa racka hartmut als 100 gäste waren
im zentrum des landes
sie zeige wie das label sich bei der
wache mädchen stutzig war der superstar
abriss war der arena wieder kaputt
konkret imam sie seit und redete aber
mehr verwendet aber für sie jetzt nach
china gekommen egal wo sie sind das ist
einfach locker dass ich war aber wohl
jeder investor cannizzaro minka sein
haus so sagte generation da hab ich hab
mal in münster johannes also 1888 haben
sie schon da sagt der großvater und und
und und die lage zieht immer noch mit
dann nur wegen der in bad sachsa
generation schon sagen dass ich jetzt
schon die elektriker nebenbei schwarz in
ankara
man hat dann nichts mehr zu sagen
vater vor ihre sachen und sowie
verstanden nicht vorschub und sexy sich
sehr gläubig sein und die herzen
kommendes jahr sollen will die das in
armenische viele und erkennt die app die
aktion extra für sie mit und sagen das
ist jetzt für rolf alina
in der lackierhalle gar nicht passt
das ist jetzt schon im regal nach dem
start vertrags am filmstandort
österreich
wahnsinn wahnsinn ich kann jetzt noch
peter schnelles vor die zusammen als
macher sich für mich super super vorbild
man seit die armen menschen sind bereit
uns jetzt aussieht und sich bereit
kerzen und früchte als wären okay
durch die einfache verhaltensweisen des
elternhaus wird er oft jahres unbedingt
machen aber vor die nur noch susan
goldpreis jetzt los zwölf stunden flug
von zürich auf san francisco und
westküste der usa
[Musik]
vier jahre lang hat susan scully vorn
geklappt
damals mit die 20.000 des hippie la witt
für die motorrad grund die da erzählt
sind eine freundschaften entstanden mit
lüthi ewigen gesehen
darum fordere ist vergangenheit
[Musik]
wie bewältigen sie in den stunden und
mit sack und pack m san franciscos oder
aus
[Musik]
noch sagt erichsen endlich wieder ihre
alte heimat im sonnenstaat kalifornien
[Musik]
articus spannung vor der reise mit
großer weg und er muss es mehr oder lage
ist so mächtig geworden
[Musik]
ab 10 uhr geöffnet und ich unheimlich
regierung so zum auch und ressourcen so
hat er hatte mich genauso gemacht
im besten fall ist nur die latte und ich
glaubte ein 40 mich nach so langer zeit
wieder mal eine überraschung zu ersparen
habe ich meine bekannte und das nach
fast 20 jahren susen wurz probieren
da ist doch vor
toto marti von true story von the hills
und santa monica zu tun
[Musik]
deine augen verloren aber darauf können
[Gelächter]
in auckland und ja
[Musik]
erfolgserlebnis ganz anders primondo und
die innenstadt und ruhiger zu bevor
jahrhundert zeigt sie in der frühen
dienstag ist ein kapitel wo arminia
vergangenheit erlebte team völkermord
weitem erste weltkrieg und die türkische
herrscher über 1 5 millionen christen
braucht
sexy standen damals sieben fahrten
denkmal zu ehren der opfer befürchtet
sie war vier jahre gestorben
cw gefühl soll dafür sorgen dass der
völkermorde über 100 jahre später nie
vergessen wird
[Musik]
dort löste man so viel trauer und
betroffenheit aber auch schön hier in
riga eines ist schon sitzt er in seinem
vater unterwegs ich bin ja weiß nicht
wie ich mich so durch druck gestern in
erinnerung respekt so laden verstorbene
arminia
[Musik]
höchst woche landete anders mit kindheit
wieder muss hat er mit seiner familie
bisher mit sieben flüchten
[Musik]
und in der usa prangerten aufs
wiedersehen mit ihrem vater
[Musik]